I'm writing every devil fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the man no me the Clone
clone fruit which allows its user to
become a clone of other people it was
eaten by Mr 2 a former agent of Baroque
works and while the fruit itself doesn't
offer any crazy combat abilities if you
have touched let's say a Giants then you
can turn into them and use their natural
crazy strength and defense for you so we
can give it at least five out of 25
points each for strength and defense
cover this route is of course all about
its special ability want to make your
friend the next king well you can become
the king and make make it true once to
fool an entire group of Marines into
opening the gates easy anything is
possible which earns this fruit an
incredible 20 points and of course it is
super useful for everyday life because
you can literally use this fruit in any
situation where you want to trick
another person or frame other people for
crimes or you can even live out your
fantasy as a fluffy cat another 20
points and there are also no real
downsides bringing its total to a
fantastic 50 points and 11th plays for
now